TORONTO TO
ARIZONA.
BARRMOVE.
EVEN WITH THE CHANGE, PALENO
COMING ON THE ANY TIME
THERE MAKING A SPRAWLING STOP
WITH HIS RIGHT
LEG.
McAVOY ABOUT IT, ALL POWER PLAY
AND SLASH CALLED THE BOARDS.
STOPPED A BIG TIME
STOP.
[MUSIC]
>> ANDY: THE BRUINS DID
EVERYTHING BUT RGERON
AND ONLY 8 OF 13 SHORTHAND
HUNDRED MAN.
CLAYTON KELLER.
ANOTHER.
CHARLIE COYLE, SHIELDS LOW THE
DO WHAT
THEY WANT IN THE THE CREASE.
CARLO, PADDLES E RHYTHM
OFFENSE, COULD PITCH
DOWN THE R THAN GET IN
SCOREBOARD.
>> ANDY: HE IS HAVING
A GOOD YEARFIRES IT
ACROSS THE
SWAY  KESSEL
GREAT HANDS ON THE STOP
NOW,
THE GOAL.
LAZAR, TO THE CENTER
AND PASS. E
BRUINS PROTECTING THE
HOUSE.
PASTRNAKSWAYMAN.
PRETTY GOOD STOP
THERE BY SWAYMAN.
PRIOR THE POST.
THEY WILL EXAM THAT HAL
SECOND TO GO.
THAT ISTHERE WAS A
>> JACK: INTO IT
AROUND.
LOOSE PUCK IT NEGATIVE
SEQUENCE WORKING
SLOT.
OFF OF THE POST.
AFTER THAT, CLCL
WITH HIM.
HE HAS GOT TO KEEP